we're still in the midst of this
pandemic we're slowly emerging out of it
but can you talk a little bit about what
you've learned about
um sleep covid um
immunity and how people should be kind
of
thinking about how their relationship
with
with the virus yeah so let me uh i'll
speak about sleep and immunity
sort of more generally and then come on
to sleep and code because
sleep has changed in at least four
different ways because of covid quantity
quality timing and dreaming
so i'll try to mentally put those
stickies up on my cerebral wall
so i come back to them but in terms of
sleep and immunity there is a
very intimate association between your
sleep health and your immune health
firstly what we know is that individuals
who report sleeping less than seven
hours a night
are almost three times more likely to
become infected by the rhinovirus
which is the common cold second we know
from a prospective study in
i think it was well over thirty thousand
women women sleeping five hours or less
a night
are more than sixty percent more likely
to develop pneumonia
across a five-year period which of
course is a critical part of the covid
mortality equation
we've also mentioned that statistic
about if you're not getting
sleep in in the week before you get your
flu shot you can't produce the normal
antibody response
do we know that that's the case for
covert yet no we don't but we're looking
at that
we also know it's the case for hepatitis
a hepatitis b vaccination two
so i think there's a an interesting case
to be made that it could make a
difference
um we also know that um
just as we mentioned before just one
night of short sleep you know just four
hours will drop those critical
anti-cancer fighting cells natural kill
cells
by 70 if that's
true then why what is sleep doing
for our emotional health and sleep
provides us with that
sort of sorry for not emotional health
for our immune health
it provides us two different benefits
firstly it's during sleep and
particularly during deep sleep
where the body will be stimulated to
produce
many more of those critical immune
factors
even better the sleep will actually
increase the sensitivity and the
receptivity of your body
to those increased immune factors
so you wake up the next morning as
a more robust immune individual sleep
will restock the weaponry
in your immune arsenal
so on that basis i think sleep has
become very relevant in this pandemic
how has sleep changed right now well as
i mentioned
firstly the studies show on average
which may be surprising to some people
sleep duration has actually increased
somewhere between about
20 to 30 minutes if you look at the
handful of studies that people aren't
commuting
not commuting kids to school so
um so that's the first issue now if you
look at that data a bit more closely
it it's not that clear it's not that
clean cut or straightforward
there is a cloud of data of people for
whom
sleep has actually become worse you know
people have lost their jobs
people don't know if they will still
have their jobs people are just
you know very anxious about the pandemic
all of those things
will you know decimate sleep of course
so sleep quantity has
um changed sleep quality has changed
also
but we also know that sleep timing has
changed
how are you getting that extra sleep
well people are going to bed a little
bit later but they're waking up
significantly later and i think this
comes back to our discussion of
chronotype
now covid because we don't have to
commute and wake up or do early morning
meetings or get the kids to school
many people have been able to sleep back
in synchrony where then with their
natural chronotype you know
it's revenge of the night owls
in that way and then the final component
is that people
and i think we we don't yet have enough
data
but there's too many people saying this
that they were dreaming more
and dreaming more about covid why would
this be i think there are two logical
explanations
the first just as we mentioned before
the later that you sleep into the
morning
the more you go into that rem sleep rich
phase so you're just giving yourself
probabilistic
chance statistically of having more
dreams
but i don't think that's the entire
explanation
we also have spoken about this idea that
rem sleep
provides this form of emotional first
aid it's overnight therapy
um in fact there's an american
entrepreneur e joseph kosman who had
this
lovely line he said that the best bridge
between despair
and hope is a good night of sleep
and i think when we're going through
these you know difficult emotionally
upheaval time of a pandemic
no wonder the brain is trying to
self-medicate it
you know this emotional situation with
the thing that it knows
provides a nocturnal soothing bomb which
is this thing called rem sleep and
dreaming
i think that's probably another
explanation as to why we're not just
dreaming more but we're dreaming about
the pandemic itself
trying to make sense of it trying to
process it trying to figure out a way to
kind of have a healthier relationship
with it that's right yeah it just
you know sleep divorces some of the
emotion from the memory
so that you come back the next day and
you feel better about those
emotional experiences because sleep has
essentially
stripped the bitter emotional rind from
the informational orange
so it's not as though you wake up the
next day and you don't remember that
emotional experience you do
but it it's no longer as emotional
and so it's not time that heals all
wounds
it's time during sleep and specifically
dream sleep
that provides emotional convalescence
[Music]
you